[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs toutes
vos idées sorties dans le département et
on commence avec le sommaire il de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
organise ses premières portes ouvertes
ce week end les 1 et 2 avril l'entrée
véhicule sera gratuite pour tous
l'occasion de découvrir de nouvelles
activités dans un poteau vers son
couteau responsable événementiel sera
avec nous pour nous en parler
une vian courtoise à l'honneur jusqu'au
6 mai le travail de teresa jean année ce
qui est à découvrir à l'hôtel de ville
une artiste pluridisciplinaire qui
expose aussi bien ses peintures que ses
sculptures et les vacances débutent
vendredi 31 mars et pourquoi ne pas en
profiter pour faire un stage de basket
en anglais mélanie poquet nous parlera
de cette activité proposée à magny les
hameaux pour se mettre dans la peau d'un
joueur de la nba
et ce week-end les amoureux de la nature
ont rendez-vous à versailles pour la
nouvelle édition d'esprit jardin de
nombreuses animations sont prévues plus
de 70 exposants des ateliers pour les
enfants mais aussi des spectacles
le potager du roi sera ouvert pour des
visites guidées les jardiniers de la
ville donneront leurs conseils
ça commence samedi à 10 heures sur le
parvis de la cathédrale saint louis et
défier le maître de fort boyard un rêve
pour petits et grands qui risque bien de
devenir réalité pour l'ouverture de sa
saison 2017 france miniature a inauguré
sa nouvelle animation fort boyard une
salle du conseil où sont réunis
plusieurs jeux de la célèbre émission le
parc ouvrira ses portes au public dès
samedi 1er avril fabrice la loure le
directeur nous en dit plus sur cette
animation
c'est une immersion et on propose à nos
visiteurs et bien défier les maîtres du
fort et défier le père fouras et de
résoudre ces énigmes
on est interpellé par le père fouras qui
nous pose une question qui nous souhaite
la bienvenue mais qui nous pose très
vite des questions et après on retrouve
les grands classiques du fort le jeu de
la voile et le
des lumières qu'il faut essayer de
remettre dans le bon ordre fait tous les
maux grand temps fort de l'émission sur
la scène des maîtres due forme est à
noter aussi que des animations autour de
la ferme sont proposées tous les
dimanches jusqu'en mai et qu'il y aura
une chasse aux oeufs le 17 avril dans le
parc et c'est maintenant le moment de
passer à notre entretien est notre
invité aujourd'hui c'est vincent couteau
responsable événementiel de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
l'île de loisirs qui organise ses
journées portes ouvertes ce week end
bonjour vincent bonjour alors ses portes
ouvertes c'est un événement vraiment
important pour vous c'est la première
fois que vous mettez ça en place tout à
fait ça fait déjà quelques années qu'on
avait imaginé ce dispositif
et puis c'est pour cette année 2010 est
on avait vraiment envie d'organiser un
événement pour le grand public pour
faire découvrir l'île de loisirs à ceux
qui ne la connaissent peut-être pas
encore et puis un événement portes
ouvertes a invité les gens à découvrir
ce bel espace qui est située au milieu
d'eux de saint quentin en yvelines
alors on le précise portes ouvertes ça
veut dire que l'entrée véhicule sera
gratuite pour tous les véhicules en fait
mais il ya également d'autres d'autres
petites animations d'autres offres
commerciales voient tout à fait dans la
demie en trois points en fait
sur cet événement le premier c'est
l'accès gratuit pour tous donc les
barrières seront ouvertes
nos agents seront à l'entrée pour vous
accueillir pour vous expliquer un peu ce
qui se passe sur l'île des loisirs
le deuxième point fort c'est une offre
commerciale effectivement sur le
week-end pour une activité à acheter
la deuxième place offerte sur une grosse
majorité de nos activités
enfin une événement une première aussi
le paintball le paint ball alors qu'est
ce que c'est qu'est ce que vous mettez
en place à lille de loisirs week-end
paint ball
donc c'est la preuve qu'on met en place
cette activité là ce sera au sein de
l'espace événementiel donc ex piscine à
vagues qui ont à la caméra on a on a
réattribué une nouvelle destination
puisque aujourd'hui c'est un espace qui
nous permet d'organiser multitude
d'événements et en l'occurrence on aura
ce week-end paintball avec deux zones
une zone pour les adultes une zone pour
les enfants avec du matériel adapté et
puis des petites activités en parallèle
comme du bubble foot du laser game et ce
genre de choses et c'est une animation
vraiment exceptionnel c'est faut en
profiter maintenant que c'est pas encore
prévu ça rejoignent la longue liste des
activités déjà proposées l'une le loisir
watts s'est affaissé vraiment c'est
vraiment pour lancer cette saison on
voulait faire une activité non habituels
comme on avait pu faire à l'époque les
aeros coûte par exemple sur les temps
donc du coup c'est vraiment en profiter
ce week-end
si ça marche bien peut-être pourquoi pas
envisager de mettre en place
régulièrement ou à plein temps le reste
mais là c'est vraiment ce week-end qu'il
faut en profiter il faudra en profiter
avec les beaux jours vous avez ouvert
également les parcours d'accrobranche
oui le week-end dernier réouverture de
branches et des loisirs qui a acquis sa
fermeture hivernale comme tous les ans
donc on a eu trois cents usagers sur le
week-end ce qui est un score tout à fait
tout à fait honorable alors justement
vous avez vu la fermeture hivernale
alors qu'est ce que ça vous a permis
vous avez créé de nouvelles choses alors
oui l'équipe de l'accrobranche je
travaille toute l'année sur l'île des
loisirs
donc effectivement sur la saison entre
mars et novembre
ils sont sur le l'accueil du public mais
sur l'hiver on doit faire plein de
choses on doit vérifier l'ensemble des
baudriers et des équipements de
protection individuelle on doit vérifier
l'ensemble des parcours changé par
exemple les matelas qui permettent à
l'arrivée des tyroliennes aussi du coup
changé des ateliers
et mettre en place de nouveaux ateliers
donc cette année on pourra découvrir par
exemple d'esclaves klein à 10 mètres de
hauteur ce genre de chose ne faut pas
avoir trop le vertige faut pas rentrer
le vertige il faut commencer bas avec un
prêt à enchaîner sur le rouge et noir le
noir qu'ont à corser un peu cette année
cercle rouge et au mais avec des
ateliers accessibles à tous le noir est
un petit peu plus physique et qui
correspondait vraiment une demande de
beaucoup
donc avis aux amateurs mais pour ceux
quand même qu'ils n'osent pas se lancer
il ya des dons qu'il était lassé
parcouru tant qu'ils sont ouverts tous
les jours pendant les vacances scolaires
précise on veut parce que normalement
c'est pas tous les jours forcément et
ses vacances de pâques juste en faisant
profiter pour organiser des stages
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ces stages
alors sur beaucoup nos activités on a
une activité annuelle et on organise
pendant les vacances scolaires des
stages que ce soit pour les enfants les
ados les adultes sur des journées sur
des week-ends sur des semaines complètes
donc on a des stages au niveau de la
voile et cette année des stages même
golf et voile le golf le matin et voile
l'après midi on a aussi la même chose en
lait qui voile équitation et voile et
ensuite des stages spécifiques voilà
vous pouvez faire un stage
perfectionnement en équitation ou
découverte un stage perfectionnement
voile en planche à voile etc
et pour finir un mot sur le village de
tickets loisirs dans l'espace
événementiel alors ce village qu'est ce
qu'on y trouve
qu'est ce que c'est alors on y trouve
plein d'activités fun qu'on met en place
vraiment pour les pour les jeunes pour
les groupes de jeunes on y retrouve tous
les activités de sport de plage
diby du volet du sandball beach rugby
etc de l'archerie tag c'est une sorte de
paintball 2 au tir à l'arc c'est
vraiment sympa à découvrir on a mis en
place l'an dernier ça a cartonné et en
plus de ça le l'espace événementiel va
accueillir dès le mois de mai multitude
de nouvelles activités qui seront
ouvertes aussi le week-end et on aura du
pilotage de drones
on ira d or à des bulles sur l'eau on
aura des des sites icomos terre des
petites trottinette à moteur avec un
circuit un peu particulier on aura même
des kartings sur l'eau donc plein de
choses à découvrir dès le mois de mai
aussi donc à noter merci en tout cas
vincent couteau est revenu sur le
plateau du 7-8 loisirs pour nous parler
de ses nombreuses animations donc
beaucoup de nouveautés à ne pas manquer
profitez-en ce week-end l'entrée
véhicule est libre merci beaucoup
vincent servi et on va parler d'une
exposition jusqu'au 6 mai guyancourt met
une artiste de sa ville à l'honneur
teresa gines année ce qui est peintre
sculpteur et graveur elle habite lui en
cours depuis 1982 et a gagné de nombreux
prix
les curieux sont invités à découvrir son
travail à la mezzanine de l'hôtel de
ville visite sur les images de nicolas
kirilow vite dessiné un voyage une écume
de nuit ou modeler l'imparfait un
dialogue entre images du réel et visions
fantastiques de la sculpture à la
peinture en passant par l'aquarelle
teresa gina nes qui ne se donne aucune
limite
j'avais envie un peu d'experts
expérimentés tous et chaque
chaque technique ma porte autre chose je
suis très sensible aux vibrations de
tout ce qui m'entoure enfer et la nature
en particulier
voilà des animaux et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que quand je suis
quelque part c'est pas de temps le
paysage que je vois c'est surtout toutes
les émotions tout ce que ça tout ce que
jean magazine en voyant ça c'est ça qui
me reste est en fait c'est cette
empreinte la réunis dans l'exposition
variations ces 42 oeuvres sont une
palette de ressenti un travail
récompensé par les prix du jury 2013 et
2015 des automnales et du salon
influence de guyancourt lors des
différents concours j'ai pu découvrir
plusieurs facettes de son travail et à
travers son travail j'ai découvrir j'ai
découvert aussi une personne et à
travers cette personne on avenue voilà
construire quelque chose ensemble
présenter ses oeuvres présenter son
travail le travail de toute une vie on a
des oeuvres qui sont depuis les années
1970 des couleurs aux ombres une oeuvre
qui a su évoluer jusqu'à aujourd'hui
comme une rétrospective des émotions de
l'artiste et on va maintenant parler
sport avec mélanie poquet pour le
rendez-vous junior de cette semaine
bonjour mme hélène bonjour cabine alors
déjà j'ai une question pour vous do you
speak english of course
pas mal pas malheur si vous souhaitez
l'améliorer j'ai une idée à vous donner
et pas besoin de quitter saint quentin
en yvelines l'amérique viendra
directement à vous et on prend la
direction de magny les hameaux et le
gymnase mauduit plus exactement alors du
3 au 7 avril le kangoo ce bac basket
club vous propose à l'ouest frenchy came
as vu mon accent je pense que moi je
vais bien sûr par contre alors vincent
porfirio et le président du club m'a
niko eeckhout et l'enseignement en fait
va être totalement axée autour du basket
100% en anglais et il est dispensé en
fait par des jeunes ou des joueurs
américains des universitaires américains
qui viennent donc dans un conseil qui
s'appelle le frenchie us socam on peut
faire confiance à un anneau coach
américain pour ne pas connaître un mot
d'anglais
alors après on le langage du corps et
puis langage du basket à mon avis là
c'est universel et puis je pense que nos
petit et nos petits et aux grands
centres 68 ans cha et donc je pense pas
que les difficultés de communication et
ses cinq jours de stage mais pour qui
pour tous en fête du moment que votre
année de naissance est entre 1997 et
deux groupes sont proposés en fonction
de l'âge le matin de 9h ali jelly ce
sera pour les plus jeunes qui eux sont
nés entre 2005 et 2009
l'après midi pour les autres il faut
savoir qu'aussi qui a trois jours pour
les adultes en nocturne il reste
principalement des places pour le stage
destiné aux plus jeunes pas de limite de
niveau c'est pour les licenciés les non
licenciés
il faut juste une chose et mais le
basket ou avoir envie de le découvrir
et d'un point de vue pratique il faut
absolument y penser parce qu'il faut
avoir un certificat médical et une
attestation de responsabilité civile et
dernières infos comptait 175 euros
et quand on voit le nombre de basketteur
français qui évolue en nba le
championnat américain
peut-être que parmi nos fuites noté
spectateurs se cache le futur tony
parker en tout cas merci mélanie 12h
parler de ce stage et les informations
s'affichent au bas de l'écran
on va continuer avec un dernier rendez
vous sports en cette veille de vacances
c'est à bois d'art
que ça se passera du 5 au 7 avril vous
êtes invités par la commune à vous
amuser en famille lors d arcy days de
14h à 17h30 trois jours d'animations
avec des thématiques différentes les
champions le mercredi le cool dès le
jeudi et le vendredi une journée tournée
vers le handisport
on écoute le responsable du service
animation jeunesse au micro de mélanie
poker justement là on a aussi décidé
aussi de d'étoffer un peu les journées
avec plusieurs types d'activités donc
célibat y avoir du manuelles et
sportives
[Musique]
on va avoir des jeux ludiques dans
plusieurs structures gonflables et donc
voilà la formule a été un peu changé on
n'y a plus plus fun et on ajuste les
petites informations justement du stage
de basket arrive justement là au bas de
l'écran
si vous pouvez les noter pour vous
inscrire n'oubliez pas ça commence la
semaine prochaine et le set loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
je vous souhaite de très bonnes vacances
[Musique]